so you know again I'm just an alum
working on some stuff that I think is
pretty cool I'm here to tell you a
little bit about that to answer some
questions hopefully tell you about some
things that you haven't heard about
before that you might find interesting
and just tell you about what it's been
like for me as an FBS grad with a
passion for agriculture who decided to
move to California and try my hand at
working in the industry working with
some of the folks who are still a little
bit skeptical about a lot of the ideas
that we learn about here at FES and you
know the other thing that's important to
think about isn't really important to me
and one of the reasons why I'm here is
that I am constantly disappointed by the
fact that there aren't more young
passionate people in agriculture and
there aren't you know more people who
look like me there are more young women
so that's another subject that we won't
talk about today but I just hope that
some of what I'm gonna tell you about
encourages you to think about think
outside the box about how you might take
your FES experience with you out into
the world and approach in an industry
like agriculture that needs more people
like us
so in putting together these slides I
tried to think a lot about my experience
about my time sitting in your place you
know what would I have wanted to hear
about this topic and I hope that I've
succeeded and again you know I'll try to
keep the jargon down I'll try to stay
focused but I get excited and I kind of
go off in one direction or another
so again if anything needs clarification
just raise the hand and I want us to be
really informal that sound good good oh
and my mom is good that's other fun
thing arrows oh yes heroes
all righty so I met I was not being
attention when Gordon asked how many of
you are doing the three credit course
and did all the readings okay
most good oh it looks it's got all the
readings okay good
so I've tried to this week incorporate
some of what Kara May has told me about
your reactions to the readings into the
slide set so you know it's really
important I'm a I'm a big picture person
it's important for me to always start
big and then dial down and the idea of
feedback loops and and the article that
I shared with you from Wired magazine
it's kind of a thread that runs through
everything that we're trying to do in
the stewardship index and I think in
sustainable agriculture as a whole and
you know some you heard about a couple
of examples of feedback loops in that
article but the bottom line is that
whenever you have a system closing its
own informational loop turning data into
useful information that enlightens us
about choices and opportunities and
spurs action that's all feedback with
this it's basically taking additional
information about a system and feeding
it back into the system and this is a
quote from Meg Wheatley in leadership in
the new science this is a quote that my
boss loves and he brings it up all the
time that the most profound strategy for
changing a living Network comes from
biology if the system is in trouble
it can be restored to health by
connecting to more of itself the system
needs to learn more about itself from
itself
and another way of characterizing this
is none of us don't know what we don't
know and I think a big portion of what
we bring to the environmental debate in
the jobs that we film you leave FBF is
an openness to asking these types of
questions know what don't we know what
could we know more about how can we
identify
opportunities to learn more about this
system that is obviously struggling
under the framework that it's been
operating with for you know the past our
many decades and I also think that the
most important impact of the stewardship
index or any of the other certification
schemes or standards that you've been
reading about is the way in which they
create exchange of information about a
broken system and create value based
relationships between stakeholders that
don't exist outside of that container
you create value based relationships
where there have traditionally only been
relationships based on buying and
selling and you know also what we're
doing is we're creating a common
language for setting goals and
establishing a path for continuous
improvement where there hasn't been one
in the past so Karen may ask me to put
together some quick points on the
impacts of the tomato industry and again
this isn't by any means conclusive I
think you'll hear a bit more about some
of this from Larry next week but you
know just as a quick glance tomatoes are
often grown in sandy soil which doesn't
hold any water and does he have any
nitrogen so a lot of what I read in
preparation for this class and what you
guys read some of doing my own research
especially in Florida where the majority
of the field tomatoes are produced in
this country this the the ecological
collage achill conditions there are not
suited for tomato production the reason
why tomatoes are grown in Florida is
because it's warm enough to keep them
alive during the winter when there's a
market for them up and down the eastern
seaboard that's also linked to the
amount of pesticide and fungicide use in
tomato production when you grow in a
warm climate you don't have frost and
you think this is all you guys know all
this
so the the pests and the and the blight
that would otherwise die from exposure
to cold temperatures persist and have to
be battled the working conditions and
social equity for laborers in the tomato
industry was sort of busted open a
couple years back when the coalition of
Immokalee Workers brought in Florida
brought and won a case about essentially
slavery in farm worker relationships
with the the producers that they were
picking for and so what we've learned
since then is that the tomato industry
is not alone and that there's a ton of
work that needs to be done in exposing
and improving working conditions in
social equity for the people who plant
and pick and wash and pack and ship the
food that we eat tomatoes are the poster
child in a lot of ways for the way in
which produce is now bred for yield you
know bread to produce an an end product
that can be packed and shipped and
reached the store without being damaged
so what's lost in that breeding for
yield is a lot of the nutritional value
and a lot of the taste profile nitrogen
inputs the not a nitrogen used to
produce tomatoes can vary widely and
there's another side later in the deck
that I'll show you that it shows a good
case study of the range of nitrogen
inputs used to bring tomatoes to market
and essentially what that means is that
in cases where nitrogen is over-applied
it's leaching into the groundwater it's
leaching into the water table and
causing and all the effects that you
guys are well aware of relative to
overabundance of nitrogen in the
ecosystem and then lastly the
profit margin on on tomatoes is no
different than the profit margin on most
produce it's very very thin and a good
example of the the very delicate balance
that exists with Tomatoes in particular
is that for the past 15 years or so
there's been a reference price of a
floor price for tomatoes produce in
Mexico imported into the US and just
this past September the Chamber of
Commerce issued a study that said I
think that we think we think the Chamber
of Commerce thinks they should remove
that floor price and so the Mexican
tomato industry is up in arms the the
floor the tomato industry is up in arms
essentially pitting the two industries
against each other the Mexican producers
are saying you know we're being faulted
for producing a better product the
Florida producers are saying you know
how can we let imports above the market
there's threats that trade negotiations
for other commodities are going to be
negatively impacted it's not decided yet
but it's just an example of how tenuous
the the balance can be relative to
imports and it's often referred to as
that the us-mexico tomato war so um
we're gonna shift gears a little bit now
I looked at the reading questions that
you guys were asked to answer and I
thought it was really interesting how
you were asked to think like a buyer or
rather think like a grower think about
how what the growers percept perspective
would be looking at the stewardship
index you know what kinds of critique
would they have what kinds of skepticism
what they have and so I'm going to give
you two examples of two different types
of companies that are operating in the
tomato industry just to to demonstrate
the diversity of companies that exist
both growing tomatoes and processing
tomatoes and bringing fresh and
processed tomato products to market just
to kind of illustrate the the way in
which
that the complexity of the marketplace
lends itself to complexity in thinking
about sustainability and how do we tell
our sustainability story to the larger
supply chain and so I thought it would
be an interesting exercise to kind of
counter the exercise in the in the
homework readings for you guys to think
about these two examples from the
perspective of a buyer so imagine that
your buyer at Whole Foods and your
responsible for the tomato category you
probably would never be responsible for
fresh and processed products but we're
playing pretend so we're gonna match the
two together and let's say that part of
your performance this year is going to
be linked to the sustainability of the
product that you buy to be sold in Whole
Foods so where think about where might
you start would you create your own
program would you turn to programs that
existed in them in the marketplace
already what types of questions would
you ask what would your frustrations be
and how would you create how would you
think about incentivizing your suppliers
to work with you in this process and so
this is kind of a mash-up but this is
something that's happening today some of
the big retailers are turning internal
looking internally they're turning to
their category buyers people whose sole
job it is to buy tomatoes and make sure
that the tomatoes are always the best
tomatoes and they're always the right
price and they're saying look we need
your help
you know your suppliers we need you to
talk to them and help us figure out how
to green our supply chain so first
example is a company called Morningstar
packing company they are they offer a
full line of bulk products I was and
that is paste tomato paste crushed diced
and pureed tomatoes so 40 percent of all
of the diced and pureed tomatoes sold in
the u.s. are produced by this company or
run through this company so if you made
a lasagna last week there's a 40% chance
at the
of tomatoes that you used if it was from
Trader Joe's or foot with most from stop
and shop it was from wall bounce or
Safeway or Kroger's or wherever Price
Chopper it came through this company
they like I said they have no consumer
facing brand so they only create
products for other companies products
and ingredients and what they do is they
harvest Paul grade unload sort heat
which is essentially cook screen which
is essentially crush chop puree
evaporate cool and fill bulk containers
for for the market now this is a company
that if you go to their website they
don't have any obvious language about
sustainability about stewardship about
water use or soil quality or pest
management nothing but I know for a fact
this is a company that is very
innovative in how they think about
resource use they supply a ton of
product to Unilever
which is probably one of the has one of
the longest standing most tried-and-true
supplier sustainability programs in the
world and they have a very strong
history of innovation they they are more
forthcoming on their website with info
about how they were the first company
ever to dedicate a whole line of
production just to tomato paste which
was in I learned something interesting
in the reading that tomato paste the
u.s. is a net exporter of tomato paste
and we export tomato paste to Italy
which just struck me is noteworthy
if pizza to thank and they were the
first company to package and sell
process tomato products in three hundred
gallon bulk containers that's now the
de-facto unit of bulk you know shipment
across the entire process tomato
industry
so next we have a company called
howlings tomatoes they are one of North
America's largest greenhouse operations
they have a consumer facing brand so if
you went to the number of retail outlets
that howling sells - you'd find a tomato
available there that has the howlings
label on it and they offer tomatoes on
the vine
beefsteak roma cocktail and grape they
have major language around
sustainability and their efforts and
sustainability on their website I'm
going to show you a slide next that
describes their waste-to-energy system
in their greenhouses they are capturing
rainwater and gray water for irrigation
they have solar installations across the
board and you know they're essentially
growing a agricultural commodity inside
a factory which is what a greenhouse is
for better for worse but it's a
completely different set of factors and
dynamics than field grown tomatoes are
exposed to another interesting thing
that I found in the readings is that the
tomatoes on vine which I guess is a how
the majority of greenhouse grown
tomatoes are sold it's completely a
marketing ploy it has nothing to do with
how ripe the tomatoes are or how they
are produced it was it's a total
marketing ploy designed by the
greenhouse industry to appeal to the
customer in the supermarket to have a
look of freshness and you know natural
origin so that was interesting to me but
long story short this is a schematic of
howlings greenhouse operations both in
Canada and in in British Columbia
Kenda and in camarillo tech Camarillo
California so this is the first combined
heat and power greenhouse project in the
u.s. it captures carbon dioxide for use
in plant fertilization engine heat from
power generation for use in heating the
greenhouse rain and green walk gray
water for irrigation and it supplies
substantial energy back to the community
grid so I hope I hope that I was
successful in in you know that
illustration that there's just a massive
range of what companies are doing in
their practices within their operation
there's a massive range in the way that
they're talking about sustainability in
their their public facing information
and there's something to think about
that I found pretty fascinating when I
started to work in this industry and I
didn't know before it's that companies
like Morningstar that don't have a
consumer facing brand they don't see the
the value in investing in telling a
sustainability story because to them the
end consumer is not part of their
equation but they are interested in
figuring out how to sell to Walmart the
the sustainability of their product so
it's a business to business relationship
that they're concerned with relative to
sustainability versus howlings who's
much more interested in curious about
the end consumers impression of the
sustainability of their product so what
I'm going to do now is just try to to
paint a bit of a picture again about the
differences between certification
standards that are thriving and
functioning in the marketplace today and
the stewardship index an angle that
we're coming to which is which is a
little bit different and the best way to
do that I found was to talk about the
functions of certification standards on
the next slide some of the limitations
associated with them and again I pulled
all of this from from the readings that
you guys did for the class
so functions of certification standards
market access adding value reducing risk
product differentiation and
provement enhancing cooperation in the
supply chain
it's the stimulation of external
economic drivers outside of the farm and
external change you know within a
farming community I used to work for
main force alliance so I like to tell a
story about how when the banana when the
when the rain forest Alliance certified
banana work was happening at random you
know farms throughout Central America
there was a lot of anecdotal evidence of
farms next door that were able to invest
in the certification process starting to
change their practices because they
looked over the fence and they saw what
was going on they heard through the
grapevine the price premium that the
banana growers for the other guy were
getting and you know that's sort of the
external change factor there's there's a
wanting to kind of match the Joneses
even if you're not investing in full-on
certification certification standards in
in some ways reduce transaction costs by
achieving greater market access in
theory deliver sustainability outcomes
and supplement public policy so if
you're that buyer that I mentioned
earlier supplying working with suppliers
of tomato products or fresh tomatoes
this is one of your few options right
now existing certification standards are
one of your few options if you want
something that's ready out of the box
your other option is to build your own
program and a lot of a lot of companies
are doing that that's one of the things
that the stewardship next is trying to
head off at the pass but you know there
there's a there's a there's a market
share that the certification standards
and and eco-labels have achieved that is
really important it's put the dialogue
about sustainable agriculture front and
center but they really still only
address
a very very small sliver of the overall
agricultural production universe and
this picture is a picture that my sister
sent me so I get pictures like this all
the time
friends family they're out in the world
they tell me I'm at Trader Joe's and I'm
waiting in line to pay for my groceries
and I saw the green frog and so remember
back in the day when the green frog
didn't mean anything and so they they
because they know me and they know my
work they have anecdotes about ten years
ago when I was trying to talk to them
about sustainability and empowered
certification and eco labeling and
there's just a lot of head-scratching
and the same kind of thing came up in a
meeting that I was in recently with the
head of one of the largest produce trade
associations in the US and he was
basically comparing what the search of
index is trying to do saying that it's
too hard
two initiatives that are better
practice-based standards-based links to
an eco label and he said the korean frog
means something when people see the
green frog they think it means something
and I turned to him and I was like what
does it mean do you know what it means
or do you just think that it means
something and I also wanted him to know
you know five ten years ago I can tell
you because I was there it didn't mean
anything it didn't mean anything to
anybody so that's just sort of a an
indication of the long game and the the
trajectory that were that we're
operating on and the importance and
keeping that that in perspective you
know there's momentum that needs to be
made now but I think that all of this
work in sustainable AG is it's really
it's evolutionary not revolutionary
we're you know we're talking about a
10-year window and it's anthropological
in a lot of ways beyond just technical
so some of the limitations the
certification standards there are
significant barriers to entry and that's
something that we'll talk a little bit
more about in a couple of slides there's
very limited monitor
evaluation so many of the standards that
are operating in the marketplace today
are based largely on practice and
performance not our sorry largely on
practice and process not on performance
so it's about what types of practices
are you employing in your operation not
about how well those practices are
generating outcomes for your farm for
the ecosystem that you're located in for
the end consumer that's buying your
products in communicating the benefits
of these certification schemes it's been
largely anecdotal the market share has
been limited despite proliferation you
know despite the fact that they're I
think the statistic that you guys sent
me with that mark last week mark
pomfritt said there's 300 different eco
labels in the marketplace today benefits
are diluted as they travel up and down
the supply chain so there are we can't
very tangibly point to benefits for the
producer or for the end consumer and
this is one of I think probably one of
my biggest points of contention and
again I feel like I can say these things
because I worked for rain forest
Alliance for six years is and I love
them and I'd go back there and in a
minute is that producers are very rarely
involved in setting the standards so
again the mindset of you are that buyer
forced to start to reckon with how green
is my supply chain these are these are
your options right now in 2013
certification standards based practice
based certifications are largely
qualitative they're limited to those who
are best performers they are linked to
practices and a prescriptive set of
practices and compliance is rewarded if
you can meet this standard then you can
be certified and you can mark it with us
and use this equal label what I'm going
to talk about next as I describe the
stewardship index is a different
approach that's rooted in the concept of
measure to manage and so that approach
is largely quantitative it's open to
anyone who's willing to start the
process it's linked to outcomes so
there's no defined path or recipe and it
rewards willingness to disclose
willingness to be to increase
transparency and so the bottom line is
that whether you're a stakeholder who's
a grower or a stakeholder who's a buyer
you know one thing for sure the good
food market is growing regardless of the
recession and the only way that you can
access your share of that market depends
on your ability to create and
communicate shared value and so a quick
definition of measure to manage is this
is this the concept that that comes up
in classes is it does anybody here this
does it mean anything to you guys no
okay so the idea of measure to manage is
it's largely a business concept and it
links to the concept of of KPIs key
performance indicators and the saying
goes that which gets measured gets
managed and that which gets managed can
be marketed so
so that's gonna kind of come up again in
a couple places as we get into details
about the stewardship index and I want
to make one other distinction here
between practices and outcomes so a
practice is essentially the the methods
that you use on your farm I'll use
irrigation for example so it's a you're
a grower and you're completing a
sustainability audit a practice based
audit or a practice based question would
read what kinds of irrigation do you use
if you use this kind of irrigation you
can meet our standard and become
certified a performance metric would
read how much water did you use this
year how much water did you use last
year how much water are you saving
through changes to your irrigation
practices so um you know why why a
stewardship index essentially there's an
opportunity to engage with the rest of
the agricultural supply chain in our
case just fruits and vegetables so I'll
tell you a bit about sister initiatives
in row crops and in dairy and in
livestock but there's an opportunity to
go beyond just the the actors that are
ready for certification now and engage a
much broader section of the agricultural
industry through the creation of a
common language for understanding
sustainability and the language that's
linked much more to business then - you
know in crazy enviros which is you know
the the threat or the accusation that we
get a lot of the time measure to manage
now and essentially having access to a
set of metrics that have been developed
through a multi-stakeholder process and
are ready and available now so that you
don't have to come up with your own set
of metrics those metrics are then used
to buy an individual operator say you
know
Morningstar packing company to assess
their own internal baseline and
understand how they perform against that
baseline year-over-year and then working
in cohorts of growers peer peer groups
of growers say all of the packing tomato
but processing tomato growers in
Northern California to turn that that
data into useful information about how
I'm performing relative to a benchmark
or relative to a peer group and then
ultimately the the value of metrics the
value of the stewardship index is
streamlining the reporting process to
your buyer partners and you know the I
think the bottom line now is that data
can back up the anecdotal claims that
retailers want to make at the point of
sale they're very much interested in
accessing the data points that will
allow them to make claims at the point
of sale about the authenticity and the
origin of products that's what consumers
are interested in not necessarily in all
of the data used to make that point but
you know buyers need to have that data
in their back pocket in order to
confidently make the claims and point of
sale that will increase increase sales
and increase patronage so a couple of
key messages behind the search if index
the vision is that a single system for
measuring sustainability performance can
meet the measure to manage needs of the
entire supply chain and reduce producers
reporting burden the value behind the
search of the next is that it can be the
tool for producers to tell their
sustainability story and get recognition
for their work and the barrier breaker
is that creating benchmarks can help
move more producers along the
performance spectrum quicker so I'm
gonna talk about this really neat case
study relative to benchmarking but I
just want to pause here make sure that
there aren't any questions
yeah exactly it's predominantly a tool
used by people involved in the supply
chain from the grower end to the buyer
and when I say buyer I mean retailers
wholesalers processors food service
companies I don't mean consumers so
that's thank you for clarifying that to
meet the the those buyers an interest in
having more data about the
sustainability of the products that
they're sourcing and selling in their
store or sourcing and serving in their
restaurant
anybody else okay
so we're basically borrowing an idea
coming out of a Unilever study where
they collected data as part of their
single agriculture code which has been
around for about 15 years and is a
really interesting program constantly
evolving but a few years back they they
gathered and compared nitrogen use data
for a cohort of profiting tomato growers
in California they found that nitrogen
fertilization rates application rates
could vary by 200% to get the same yield
so they took that information back to
these growers and they said here's the
deal some of you are paying for and
applying 200 percent more nitrogen than
others of you to get the same exact
yield per acre same exact you know
tonnage and that peaked an interest you
don't have to necessarily go to some go
to anyone and tell them that what
they're doing tell them that what
they're doing is wrong you just have to
show them that someone else is doing it
in a better way and all of a sudden you
have their interest you have their their
desire to figure out more of these
figure out where more of these types of
situations lie and so essentially what
we're working on in the stewardship
index is replicating
this exact type of data collection
reporting back creation of benchmarks
high-end and low-end scope of resource
use for water use energy use nutrient
use and soil health and then reporting
that information back to cohorts of peer
growers so growers of a particular craft
in a particular region who feel that
there is comparability across their
their production and so who is the
stewardship index it's a question that I
get a lot of the time this is our
Coordinating Council which is
essentially our board I spend about 75%
of my time working with this group I
mentioned to Aaron and Jonah and Cara
main Gordon earlier that I call myself a
stakeholder whisperer it's my job to
help all of these folks identify common
interests and elevate those common
interests and quell fears and concerns
raise them address them do so in a way
that uses really good process really
good protocol so that everyone feels
confident that we're moving through
consensus moving together as an industry
towards some real change and that to me
is one of the things that's most unique
about stewardship index is this emphasis
on collaboration on working together
across these siloed stakeholder groups
most of these people especially the
people in the first two categories
growers and buyers they don't come
together outside of business
transactions they've all identified an
opportunity to solve problems
collectively that cannot be solved into
by individual companies the other thing
that is really interesting and I take to
heart is that especially in the first
two groups all of the individuals who
represent those institutions they have a
deep personal connection and commitment
to sustainability they fight every day
against their company's lack of come
and passion for sustainability so that
makes for you know some pretty heartfelt
engagements when you get the big guy
from the national potato council who is
my buddy and nemesis all wrapped in one
sitting across from big guy from our gal
from Safeway listening to them have a
dialogue about why they are involved in
this crazy process to begin with you
know that the level of personal
commitment despite the lack of
commitment on the part of the industry
or the part of the individual company or
trade group is pretty impressive that's
one one of the reasons why I stick
around so um a bit about our process
again it's not super clear but this just
explains how we go from how the sitting
around a table and scratching your head
and think how would we measure
sustainability to actually offering a
tool up to the industry so small working
groups made up of experts from those
three different stakeholder groups meet
over the Co have met over the course of
the past two years to say how would we
what type of science would we want to
use to measure you know water use in
fruit and vegetable production and how
do we balance that science with ease of
use on the farm by growers and then they
take those proposals and refine them and
eventually advance them to the
Coordinating Council the board that I
just showed you they debate kind of the
larger scale implications this is how my
constituency would feel about it well
this is my line in the sand and then
once that group approves the metric it's
pilot tested with you'll see a bit more
about the pilot testing next but you
know essentially taken from the
theoretical realm and ground truths with
growers in fruit and vegetable
operations across the country then
there's peer review there's you know
open public comment and eventually the
metrics are approved for use by the
broader industry
these are the these are the four metrics
that we're working with right now that
have kind of made their way through that
process acre inches applied per ton
harvested and per crop transpiration so
that's the water metric the new
treatments are up on the right-hand side
pounds of negative caffeine per ton
targeted energy is total BTU per ton
harvested and soil is organic matter
relative to organic matter potential and
I'm gonna kind of speed along a little
bit cuz I want to get to some Q&A but
essentially the the pilot goals are to
test that this thing is useful not just
to growers but to buyers as well to test
that it's a valuable valid approach to
helping buyers and growers and NGOs
environmentalists and social NGOs have a
productive dialogue rooted in
quantitative info about getting the
outcomes we need the changes that we
need on the ground from fruit and
vegetable production and again that's
another difference about stewardship
index you have a lot of initiatives
that's been years developing these 700
page audits or 700 page standards before
even taking the thing out into the field
to see how it runs on the ground so a
couple of quick screenshots we it's an
excel-based calculator where growers use
their they sit down at their computer in
their office and they take a look back
at all of their records and they pull
out the relevant data points for all
those metrics that I just described and
they implement they put me in put them
into the calculator there's tons of
guidance and reference and drop down
tables you guys saw the user guide which
has descriptions definitions boundary
definitions step-by-step instructions
and then the dashboard is essentially
the punch line math for the groceries
then the metrics calculated screenshot
of the user guide and so in 2012 we were
you know doing essentially
a sales pitch traveling around the
country meeting with growers engaging
them on these concepts and getting their
feedback both on the metrics themselves
on the calculator and on how useful this
whole thing was to them and right now
we're at the point where we're analyzing
the data from the 2012 pilot and we're
making refinements and getting ready to
report back to growers in both one one
on one and in small feedback sessions so
just a bit about the the scope of the
pilot work that we've done crops States
and number of growers and geography and
you know just some some quick examples
of ways in which these concepts are
currently being utilized Walmart this
past fall did a produce sustainability
assessment where they worked with
growers of five different fruits and
vegetables to start to ask some of these
questions and figure out what they could
learn from the data the almond Board of
California is implementing a pretty
extensive pilot a company based in
Colorado called Farm Fresh Direct has
developed a breed of potato that they
believed to be much more efficient in
terms of water use and they're
essentially using the stewardship index
process and the stewardship index
platforms as a way to show data about
the the water use efficiency of this
potato and to communicate that to a
bunch of the really large scale bot
retailers that they want to sell this
potato to there's a couple of sister
initiatives that I mentioned that are
looking at other sectors of the
agriculture industry the field to market
has a tool called the field print
calculator it's essentially the same
thing but for row crops corn rice wheat
soy and cotton there's a mission there's
a similar initiative in the dairy dairy
industry led by the Innovation Center
for u.s. dairy there's a carbon
footprint
tool called the cool farm tool that
Unilever has used extensively and then
one of my favorites that I'm learning a
lot about and making a lot of friends
with is this sustainable apparel
coalition I'm sure that a lot of you
guys have heard about it so it's similar
kind of initiative but focusing on
apparel they have a really fabulous kind
of institutional level of institutional
capacity that the stewardship index
doesn't have yet staff board you know
fun lots of funding all that so